president trunk meets with top military
leaders tonight he's telling two of the
key advisors Steve Bannon and jared
kushner to stop fighting the president
said nothing about that controversy
yesterday when new Supreme Court justice
new horses was sworn in the ceremony
marked the end of a more than your long
battle to fill that seat on the High
Court major Garrett is at the White
House with the reported high level truce
among his top advisors made you a good
morning good morning all quiet in the
West Wing that's the public line anyway
and for the first time in weeks it
appears to be valid because that's
because president Trump through his
chief of staff ordered his top warring
advisors populist Steve Bannon and
multi-millionaire son-in-law jared
kushner to cool it and cool it now and I
got it done in the first 100 days that's
even nice the Rose Garden swearing-in of
supreme court justice Neil Gorsuch
offered a tranquil counterpoint two
weeks of white house in fighting
President Trump has ordered to end I've
always heard that the most important
thing that a president of the United
States does is appoint people the
Gorsuch confirmation transcends the
pitched battle between Bannon and
Kushner over ideology access and clout
what is the president's perspective on
the ability the current ability of his
senior advisors to work as a team he's
very confident in that late last week
chief of staff rinds Priebus ordered a
face-to-face truce between the two
senior advisers
matters came to a head when Bannon
opposed the missile strikes in Syria and
Kushner supported them Bannon has
steadily lost ground to Kushner in
recent weeks his fall started with the
clumsy rollout of the president's first
travel ban executive order which federal
courts blocked and the White House
abandoned then the Obamacare repeal
failed while Bannon worked on
negotiations and last week mr. Trump
removed Bannon from the National
Security Council Kushner meanwhile is
leading key White House Task Forces
traveling to Iraq with the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff and planning
head of state visits including the
mar-a-lago summit with Chinese President
Xi Jinping my father speaks for himself
in an interview with CBS this morning
Ivanka Trump Kushner's wife and also a
senior adviser to the president
downplayed the West Wing drama I do
think we have a lot of different
viewpoints at the table but they're not
at odds with one another Bannon sees
Kushner and his allies as globalist
Democrats while Kushner regards the
bannen faction as harshly nationalist
and Bannon himself even a bit vengeful
but this uneasy peace appears to be
holding one outside White House adviser
described it as a mix between can't we
all just get along and don't tase me bro
Nora well that's a new one all right
major thank you